so people were actually
booing in my theater
at the end of the movie
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
so Spider-Man across the spider verse is
now out and this movie has been getting
so much hype from the people who saw it
you know a week or two early and
honestly I kind of get it now disclaimer
I'm somebody who doesn't typically get
overly excited for animated movies I
don't know why just when they come out
I'm like oh that kind of looks cool most
of them I'm like I'm not gonna see that
but there are some that I genuinely
enjoy I just don't get overly excited
about them but Spider-Man across the
spider verse was very different
especially after watching into the
spider-verse I thought that was just
really really good so I was really
looking forward to watching this one
like really excited and this is what I
thought about it I was really excited
for it and I was really hoping it didn't
disappoint and it didn't except for one
part which I'll talk about in a bit but
no spoilers no spoilers this is a
spoiler free review now let's talk about
the animation because we have to but we
don't need to talk about it much because
in all honesty it's amazing
I mean it really is I just uh I read
that they said it took two to three
years just to do the animation for
spider Punk alone he was a phenomenal
character who I actually ended up loving
when I didn't think I was going to but
you know you put so much time and so
much care in this animation and it's
amazing it's visually amazing it's
spectacular it you watch it and it's
you're just like in awe of how good it
is right so it's into the spider-verse
but somehow a little bit better
it is I don't think anyone could really
argue the animation isn't amazing for
this and it's kind of a just a
Spider-Man thing just an across the
spider verse into the spider-verse thing
right there have been others that have I
think tried to mimic it a little bit
like Puss in Boots the last wish had
some really kind of similar animation
but when I saw it I thought they took
that from the into the spider-verse
franchise right so they are kind of like
I feel like Pioneers in their own sense
of the animation style and I did love
Puss in Boots The Last Wish by the way
that's a good one too but animation is
amazing and you don't really need to say
more than that all right so the voice
acting and the characters themselves I
loved them really even the ones you're
not so like I love the villains of this
movie there are kind of a few a couple
right I won't give that away but the
spot the main villain
truly a delight as weird as that sounds
I actually really like the character and
his development
was really good and really smart they
did that in a really smart way to where
it's kind of like
this could have been a fail with this
villain like it he's funny and it's kind
of like okay you did too much or you
didn't do enough but they did it just
right the spots actually a really good
villain and
I can't wait to see more I'll leave it
at that until just a bit but Miguel
O'Hara Spider-Man 2099 I mean Oscar
Isaac crushed it as the role I mean
really everybody right everybody who was
in there just did an amazing job but
overall this is a story about spider
Gwen or Spider Woman as she's called in
this movie Gwen Stacy and of course
Miles Morales and it's really cool
because you dive really deep into Gwen's
story and she's my favorite
Spider-Man like iteration out there I
love Gwen Stacy spider Gwen she's my
favorite she is and I was so glad we
could go into her world and it's a
pretty deep story overall which is
really to me what made the movie because
I knew the animation was going to be
good and let's be honest like we know
the voice acting is going to be good we
saw the first one and we know the new
actors that are coming in this one we
knew it was going to be good even Andy
Samberg had a role right and his role
was fantastic I loved his character I
loved his voice everyone did a great job
but I knew it would come down to the
story and for me
it's a pretty dang good story like as
far as Spider-Man stories go
yeah it's it's really good and it's
really deep they touch on a lot of
different things but that's why it makes
it so good
the ant I will say that the animation
it's kind of cool that they did do it
this way because we saw a lot of stuff
in this movie that you wouldn't see
otherwise like it took two to three
years to do the animation for one
character imagine what that would be
like in real life like if it was a live
action movie so truly what we saw the
web slinging the flips you know all the
acrobats that you know it's animated but
it's like it's really cool and you
couldn't see that in a live-action film
unfortunately you wouldn't get as much
so it is actually a benefit to this
movie that is animated because it's
really awesome but the story is
incorporated with that so well
you're really drawn in and I when I see
a really good movie I'll clinch up a
little bit that's what I was doing in
this movie in an animated movie which I
don't typically do even ones that have
like high stakes I'm not like oh but in
this movie I'm literally kind of on the
edge of my seat wondering what's gonna
happen here so the story of Miles the
story of Gwen and really the other
Spider-Man that we run into it's just
really really cool and overall it made
the movie for me because it actually
pulled me in it made me get invested in
the main characters and the side
characters as well but it also is just a
dang good Spider-Man Multiverse story I
feel like we've had a lot of movies
where the Multiverse isn't exactly what
we have wanted it to be or have thought
it was going to be for a particular
story but this one just works it really
does the story is really good and no
spoilers will do a spoiler talk later
but man some of the things that happen
I'm just like
that's awesome didn't expect it makes
perfect sense fits perfectly I love it
can't wait to see what happens next now
the reason people were buoying at the
end of my movie
you have to know going into this movie
it is a part one of a part two
that's just what it is right so across
the spider versus a part one and Beyond
the spider verse which comes out in a
year is the part two so this stuff's not
gonna get wrapped up all in this movie
and I think the majority of my theater
didn't know that because they all booed
when it said you know this is part one
pretty much
so know that going in but the ending it
does it it it's it does the perfect job
of making you go I want to see what
happens next right now and it was like
it's like two hours and 20 something
minutes long it's a long movie and I was
sitting there going like no I wanna
watch more I want to watch the rest of
this play out I could watch the second
movie right now that's how good it did
at pulling you in at captivating you so
know that going in that's why they were
booing not because well I did hear some
people yell that it was kind of boring
because it's kind of long I didn't think
it was born at all and trust me I
typically think animated movies
are boring but this one I think nailed
it in pretty much all of the possible
things that you can nail it in it did a
good job all the categories that you
want to just check off here like did we
do this did we do this did we do this
nailed it in each category it's overall
an amazing film and true Spider-Man fans
are going to love this film and even if
you're not just a Spider-Man fan in
general if you're a movie fan or just a
Marvel fan or just whatever this movie
is fantastic either way you look at it
it's just all
good I did think there was a lot more
action in the beginning but the way it
ended really just makes you want more
and it's like you almost get exactly
what you want and then they're like hold
on
that's the next movie and you're like no
no it's like you love it but you hate
I want it now but overall Spider-Man
across the spider-verse it was a great
movie I think I Gotta Give it
a 9 out of 10 probably losing a point
because it is a part one and they're
making us wait for that second part
hopefully beyond the spider verse I can
give a 10 out of 10. but honestly the
movie was amazing I think everybody's
gonna really enjoy it have you seen it
let me know what you thought about it if
you haven't let me know how excited you
are about it in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos don't forget to
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching wolf
please